have you ever did I ask you this last
time you did have you ever almost died
many many many many many many times pick
one uh was right in the back of a truck
at the bed of a pickup truck when I was
in college oh yeah I am the truck
you're riding in the back of a pickup
truck in the bed of a pickup truck just
flying down why do they call it a bed
anyone's you're not sleeping back there
there was a cab why is the cab of a
truck a cab there's a cab in the front a
bed at the back what come on Seinfeld
find it he has a stroke what is this oh
yeah okay I'm taking you to your new
apartment when you're moving in the
mattress there it is he just melts like
like he drank from the wrong
uh Last Crusade why does it start at 150
Ford F-150 250.
you made 149 of these before you came up
with this one
[Music]
I mean can you imagine if I'm getting
mad at us for doing these bits on him
he's so mad what are you doing it I uh I
paved the way for you you pave away you
take away and what are you using to pave
anyway asphalt concrete what's more
stable don't be an [__] he's becoming
a civil engineer as we continue on
Seinfeld in other jobs
we need to move units
are you diversifying any of your
portfolio at all there's a lot of
organic Synergy happening what does that
even mean I was in the bed of a pickup
truck coming back from
Mexico into South Padre Island Texas on
spring break with some friends I was
intoxicated I'm not proud of this moment
the gentleman driving the truck was
intoxicated I'm not proud of that moment
and we caught hitched a free ride from a
man we don't know but I know he had been
drinking I probably definitely knew
and the truck was bouncing around over
this bridge rickety bridge going from
Mexico to South Padre Island
and I sobered up because I mean for a
hot second because we swerved a little
bit because a truck had been pulled over
on the side of the road and we almost
clipped it
and I realized this hits I fly out of
this thing and either ping-pong my head
against some of the bridge iron before
falling in before falling into the ocean
or I fly out of the back of this thing
onto this narrow two-lane bridge and get
immediately run over by a Cascade of
cars
and it [__] me up I held so tightly
onto the sides just like wishing to the
universe that we would make it okay and
it was one of those things where yeah
but the whole time
I kept thinking this is it I am going to
die like this like it was us just
clipped missing clipping that car and
swerving yeah was the
I I it was a wake-up call for I could I
was like I should never get in these a
car with someone who's been drinking
again I didn't know but we did know do
you know what I mean oh yeah it was so
back to my observation yeah you know dad
jokes right there the neck whenever the
neck goes back they're drunk somebody
Josh Ruben told me it's when their eyes
go before their head so say something to
me
have you been drinking tonight sir oh my
God they follow
Joshua it is because the eyes are still
working at full speed yeah the eyes
aren't drunk but the body is the body's
drunk the eyes are like oh God he's
drunk no we have to take care of all
this over it looked that way
good boy
good boy all right now close your eyes
for a second oh my God how much of life
is you just want to be babied and
getting drunk you need to be a baby you
need help you need someone to be like do
you need a burrito buddy like we love it
yeah well in the morning you're hungover
and someone's like do you need another
burrito yeah I want two
oh yeah
[Music]